you moved to LA a lot of us moved to LA
I moved to LA I was living in Boston I
moved here way back in the day well yeah
I moved out here in 85 really yeah how
was it different what's the what's the
cocaine difference
like what's the we talked about product
is so much better than now then oh no
probably not
I never I never did any of that stuff he
was like my TV's not me asking you I
mean like a melt that's around that is
just around what's like I am a complete
square so much so that I worked on
different TV shows and was completely
aware that anybody unaware that
completely unaware that anyone would be
doing drugs really like I've done start
out live and I had no idea that like
people in other rooms might be doing
something really my entire comedy career
I've been like watching my cholesterol
and working on my copy of my room and
people are in other rooms doing whatever
and I'm like I just assume everyone's
hard at work you know I don't you're
asking the wrong guy but this girl will
have you for forever you'll be here
forever y'all healthy and [ __ ] oh god no
I'm Irish Catholic we'd go early no but
I but I minds of self-loathing and you
know I'll fall apart like an old poplar
tree I know I've got like five years to
go and then I'll just crumble all the
sudden but I assumed I assumed like the
80s in LA I thought I sound like the bus
driver did a line it was just like
alright next like ya know in Heights III
swear to god I
I was out here and my writing partner
time Greg Daniels the office king of the
hill Parks and Recreation Greg Daniels
brilliant guy he and I were out here and
we would both we were total squares and
didn't do any drugs didn't even drink
I remembered someone at one time I
walked into a room when I was like 22
and some guys were doing cocaine they're
like hey do you want some cocaine and
what oh that's all right that stuff
interrupts your heart rhythm
that's the last time Dexter got off it
anyway this was interesting uh great we
learned we learned about each other are
we learning so much about okay okay
situation now he and I never leave the
house yeah
fear it's out there yeah I haven't tried
it either giving a weather report I know
Cain but I haven't tried it either but
on a very special episode of Conan we
should just go for it
garage comedy special Jerrod Carmichael
8:00 debut Saturday March 11th at 10:00
on HBO and stay tuned to this program
for a very special coked-up Conan Andy
[Applause]
you